okay I'm going to go ahead and and start
this Committee of conference here uh
this bill is relative to HB
1298 the definition of part-time
teachers and we do have a side by side
that's been provided to us one side the
left side showing the house version and
the right side the Senate
version um there is a significant
difference between between the two
versions so right now I'm just going to
open this up to discussion as I have the
other Committee of conferences and is
there
anybody wants to lead out
here let's have the Senate mind yeah so
again I I can speak for um the people
have voted for the Senate
position um that's qualified yeah uh so
again the intent here was on the Senate
side was to allow local school boards
fle uh an increased amount of
flexibility uh not involving the State
Department of Education with the
exception of a background check um and
to allow local school boards and
trusting that local school boards would
be able to find those POs people within
their Community to fill what a part-time
need that they have um and again it may
be a situation where um I'm going to use
especially the specials the art you know
those kind of things music um a school
may not have a reason to have a
full-time art teacher but they have a
reason to have a full-time art teacher
that could teach in five different
classes or share it with another school
district and so the ability to have the
local board decide that the the local
artist that has an art shop downtown on
Main Street is goes through an
application process goes through a uh a
review and they can make the
determination that we think this art
teacher whe this art uh um professional
um could teach art in our school with no
problem um and they make that
determination not involving the State
Board of Education and hire that teacher
for a half a day um to be able to come
in and teach once one class in a middle
school one class in the high school um
if that's what's necessary um but we
trust in that the school boards should
be able to make the determination and
evaluate their people like they do all
other positions um without the Board of
Education
involved okay it sounds as if you're
you're speaking to
eliminating um BC on on the house side
on rment number one uh B and
C um is that correct uh right again the
the bill before us is amended by the
Senate so so the Senate position is
talking position I get I'm guessing um
and so the question is whether they go
back to the house position yeah so yeah
so again I'm speaking strictly to the
Senate position and again I think you
know again we have we have requirements
of a bachelor's degree of content area
um and I I I'd argue that not
necessarily every content area would
have tests not everybody has a
bachelor's degree but they'd be
completely qualified to be able to teach
and so um if if the school board again
the local hiring Authority determines
that they're going to have an evaluation
process we're not just saying anybody
can walk in and apply what we're saying
is well andbody can walk in and apply
but it's not without an evaluation the
school districts have the right to
create whatever policies they want
around so we'll talk to uh you know one
of the things I was just talking to Mr
app about was um you know the content
exam could a school board and its local
policy for hiring a part-time teachers
establish a Content exam as part of that
sure that's up to them to determine what
their qualifications they want with the
their part-time teachers are um I think
this allows for the greatest flexibility
given the teacher shortage um to allow
especially business professionals or
Professionals in their industry whether
I'll use an automotive class right that
maybe still in a high school not at a
CTE um you can bring a local mechanic in
who may have the skills to teach and yet
doesn't have a bachelor's degree right
if a school wanted to offer a one class
in wood shop they can bring a carpenter
in and and have that Carpenter teach it
may not have a bachelor's degree and I'm
not sure there's a Content exam for that
person but why we require that Carpenter
or that electrician or that that or that
auto mechanic to go and get a
certification from the Board of
Education um so again I think that
leaving it at the local Schoolboard
level for part-time positions make sense
let those districts establish their own
criteria for what they believe let them
use their own judgment for what they
believe um because I'm sure and I know
from being on the school board that
there are people that come with a
certification from the Department of
Education that we don't keep on on keep
educating so it's not a guarantee just
because someone has certification from
doe means they're going to be a great
teacher um uh so this just recognizes
that flexibility gives the flexibility
especially considering the shortage that
we're undergoing in education right now
further
discussion Mr chair yes I was just
reading yesterday what they're trying to
do with the veterans coming home and
having finished their service that many
of them are extremely qualified for all
kinds of skills to be taught in in the
school and I think that's
a good source of uh a part-time
teachers so there are groups of people
available that could do the teaching
that don't have a certificate of you
know from a teacher
College uh where in this bill is it
talking about certification in a teacher
College I don't think it does say that
uh Senator so sure so look at section c
in your bill right says if the New
Hampshire Department of Education
determines this requirement is not
met right so again we're involving the
state in some sort of certifying aspect
um to qualify an individual and and
again I think local school boards are
more than capable our elected officials
at the local school board are more than
capable of determining what employees
will meet the need of that District
without this oversight of the Department
of Education I I think we need to get
some clarification here um we initially
when this bill came to us it talked
about certification this was changed as
you see right at the top of the house
version where it says part-time teachers
semicolon adjunct
authorization so they are now going to
be receiving adjunct authorization is
adjunct authorization the same as
certification that's the question I have
and I was I was indicated maybe that can
be clarified by the the bureau or the
department sitting here but I need to
have a response to that particular
question uh if it's adjunct
authorization then I if we're concerned
about certification and all the
consequences of certification where that
leads to and working with other teachers
in the building and all that and Labor
Relations um I would think that um
adjunct authorization would not be be
the same but um I'm going to call
forward uh Mr applebe for some comment
on that question I
have thank you Mr chair good morning
everyone uh Steve applebe Department of
Education um so we use a number of terms
in the Bureau of credentialing the
overriding umbrella term as I explain it
is the word credential
and within that under that umbrella we
have lure we have
authorization right lure is a teacher
license and a principal license and so
forth they're fully licensed and that
word has meaning around the country and
the word license is typically a word
used when it's a government entity
giving out something as opposed to the
word certification which we've moved
away from because
certification very often like Microsoft
I was a Microsoft certified systems
engineer for years certifications are
given out by non-governmental entities
right so we use the word license first
of all so um when we're talking about
Educators we give out licenses right um
we also give out authorizations so we
give out intern authorizations today
that's a person on an alternative
pathway an authorization is not a
license but they are both
credentials so they fall under the term
credential and we do that as well for uh
misconduct purposes investig ative
purposes code of conduct code of ethics
purposes we use that term credential but
then when you drill into it we use lure
and we use authorization and
authorization is not a
license so that's how we Define them as
being different and we don't use
certification if we can avoid
it I hope that clarifies a little yes so
again so as you look at section three of
the bill right so we are talking about
um the last sentence of of section uh C
on page one right it says um the hand
Department of Education for the
determination as to whether an adequate
occupational experience is documented to
justify the issuance of an adjunct
authorization so here again we're
requiring the Department of Education to
issue an authorization for an individual
that school district you know and I just
don't think that's necessary to get to
for a part-time position to have the
Department of Education involved and
qualifying someone that does local
school board can qualify in and of
itself question does
the department have then no
responsibility to ensure oversight to
meet the minimum Public School approval
standards to ensure that music is being
taught and physical education is being
taught or special education or any of
our areas that were under the criteria
for an adequate education are taught
appropriately or is that now going to be
uh provided to the Local District to
make that decision
I'm Sor you asking me or him well I'm
asking anybody can help me out with that
because I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I am
really with the old phone number uh I'm
I'm really concerned here that yeah I I
see we have some things listen under an
A B and C uh I'm seeing that all that's
being
subtracted and there there is no
criteria which is being set forth for
this
authorization which is a credentialing
issue not a licensing
issue and that so does when we're
talking
authorization is that the department
have nothing to play with that or to do
with
that I if if I may I think um elsewhere
in the bill if memory serves we
mentioned the criminal history record
check clearance that we would give out
clearance is another type of credential
that we do have um the authority to
resend if there is a misconduct
situation that occurs so um an
individual would still be coming if if
the other language was struck around
authorization I would if the state board
approved you know adopted rules I would
assume that that
clearance could be could be rescinded
but that wouldn't speak to qu
qualitative you touched on the other
point that I have a concern with in the
Senate version it says they seek a
criminal history records check
background check they meaning the
individual not the department whereas in
ours in in the house version The Local
School District shall seek so you have a
local government agency seeking this
criminal background check and or our
clearance uh from the Department of
Education um
who who who initiates that well current
state statute states that if if a a
school district hires you you have to
have a background check locally and and
the school board must have uh policies
in place regarding that check who
initiates that check and the individual
goes and gets that check designates the
local school district as the recipient
of that
check okay we've now gone in a direction
where new applicants and teacher prep
applicants must also get a clearance and
bus drivers from the department
M Mr chair if I can again so I use the
example I'll go back to my coaching
experience I had to get a background
Corey check um when I was coaching
because it was a requirement for me to
coach um but again I went and submitted
the paperwork to the state police and
then I designated the to be delivered to
the local school board who then verified
I was not a danger to the students um
and were able to allow me to do that
this follows that same exact process
that's outlined in 198
4-c I'm sorry wrong wrong sorry it's
1983 um so again we're following that
same procedure we currently already use
that's not new ground for local school
boards to deal with non-credentialed
individuals who still need to have a
background check
yeah further
discussion why is it uh for walking
through I'd like to know why the Senate
version uh went to 30 rather than 20
hours per
week why why did what 30 versus 20 hours
again I think we use the federal
guideline for what's defined as a
part-time position um which is under 32
hours there do you think there's any
consequences I I'm just asking all the
questions are buzzing through my head
here but do you think there's any
consequences to allowing 30 hours per
week when you divide that by five that's
6 hours per day that becomes then a
full-time teacher well again what we
were accounting for is the fact that you
may have a teacher that doesn't
necessarily teach in a high school for
six hours a day but may teach in a high
school for a couple hours a day teach at
Middle School a couple hours a day go
down to the elementary school and maybe
teach a couple hour days none of which
have room for a full-time employee in
their
budget so we're allowed for the fact
that you'll have and never mind
individual districts you may have an ESS
say you that hires a person and they
they teach in different districts so we
didn't want that to be the cumulative
effect of they hire a part-time teacher
that teaches three different districts
um but under the SAU language they would
be disqualified if they taught more than
20 hours even if they try to teach in
three different
districts and they don't necessarily
teach of five days a week either it
could be less than that all depends on
the all depends on the subject matter
and the curriculum so we use we use 30
strictly because of the Federal
definition of what a part-time person
is do you have any objections to
reducing that from 30 to
20 that's a new
question do I have an objection to what
re to reduce that from 30 to
20 well I mean 20
is what do you get for 20 it seems to me
if you're going to hire a teacher you
want to have them as much as possible if
it's part-time If part time is 30 hours
a week then you have more flexibility in
using this teacher in different areas on
different if we talk about an SIU in
different
districts so Mr chair I i' I'd make the
comment if 30 hours a week gets you to a
yes and that's the only thing we change
I'd agree to 20 hours a
week but if we're going to talk about a
bunch of more changes and I'm not going
to agree to it right now I'll have
further conversation about what we're
talking about okay let's go down to the
next one so we had you yes you're
willing to change if we change nothing
else uh B on the house side stipulates
that the individual must have earned a
bachelor's degree or hire with a major
in or related to the field of
authorization and must submit passing
scores on the content knowledge exam or
exams required for authorization area if
exists if one exists
um is there any uh rationale why you're
saying that I I've heard you saying you
you you could be a certified you know uh
data person in Microsoft or something
such as that and well qualified to with
the content and knowledge uh I I
understand that but in terms of
um other areas um why is is a bachelor's
degree a hang-up or would it be a
sociate degree or or just that there's
just just saying it's too much control
from on I and the local is not able to
hire the person you want I'll take
answer B
yeah right so again the idea being is we
have the Senate's position was that we
have we have trust and faith in local
school boards to hire the person I don't
need it I don't think in this part-time
situation that the state needs to start
specifying all kinds of criteria let the
local school boards have the control to
to to go through the applications to
hire the the best candidate without hard
uh requirements um again we're talking
about a part-time position and and if we
get down to 20 we're talking about a
very limited part-time position um again
I I don't think it's necessary for us to
create that I I would expect that any
school board that's going to hire
somebody will develop a policy
underneath their own that will set some
of this criteria for what they require
um but I don't think the state needs to
do
this and if you talking about for
example the welder
probably is not going to have a
bachelor's degree may or may not but
obviously is extremely skilled in the
area that he or she will be teaching we
already have that provision in Career
Technical
education right but again as alternative
certification but again what what
happens if you're teaching in a regular
high school I go back to the electrician
the carpenter the auto mechanics some
schools don't go to CTS and still have
those programs that may want to hire a
carpenter to come in what exam are you
going to give to a carpenter for a
part-time position
and we have alternative certification
routes again at the state level high
school for any level through 12 where
you work one we extended that to two
years in the past I believe the past
year uh to attain that alternative
certification and then you're also
enrolled in a teacher prep program of
some kind in that area my my concern is
that the the area for example if you're
you're have a shortage in let's say
social studies Civic
and you have a person that's come in
that's got a Bachelor's degree in social
studies or history and government or
some related field economics or
geography um then that person obviously
has a background in that skill knowledge
area that is to me a bar which raises it
up over the person who's coming and says
I've done this and done that and that
but
there's there's no real accountability
that they done all that is
there so the question is do you trust
your school board far it out to the
appropriate people right so is a school
board going to hire a person with a
sociology degree to teach physics I'm
pretty sure I I would trust that my
school boards are not going to do that
and that they're not going to provide
those kind of things I trust my school
boards to make those determinations
right these are elected leaders that are
there to to um to uh make sure that our
students get the best education possible
so are they going to hire sociology uh
person with a sociology to teach physics
I would say no I trust that they will
not do that I don't think they need a
state directive and a state mandate to
do
that where is this going to stop where
where is it going to stop are we going
to then have other categories like you
need a chemistry teacher and we're just
going to open it up to anybody that can
come in and say I can teach chemistry or
we have requirements now that you be
certified in that area you take the
practice examination in that
area so we there is a standard that will
parallel the academic standards which we
have in place uh I'm having a hard time
swallowing
this well it seems to me if you're
talking about a special area like
chemistry obviously you need to have
experience in chemistry maybe even a
baloria degree in chemistry or maybe
having worked in a chemistry situation
for years and years and years and you
know it inside out but I would imagine
that somebody's teaching chemistry will
have had a baloran
degree academic preparation in that
subject
matter Senator P you had your hand up
too a while I know we're here to discuss
this the um Senate's position on this
has passed I just want to offer as one
of my um fellow confer has noted that
you know I have a minority position on
this that some of the U some of the
concerns that you brought up repres pres
lad aligned with some of the concerns
that I had about the amount of time um
and calling them teachers when there's a
teacher certification required on one
side and NW and this is this position
getting a hall pass I think the original
intent of this was was good that if you
have someone in your community
especially the smaller communities that
has a specialty like you know we talked
about say you know specialty in arts a
specialty in a certain you know cultural
educational area that you want to bring
into the classroom somebody who's done
computer has computer skills that they
can't locate a teacher to do or need to
augment the education I can see the
value in that but I think that where
you're starting to line up is along the
lines of is it a teacher or is it not a
teacher um so I just wanted to bring
that it's not that those things were not
discussed there was disagreement on them
but they were
discussed representative uh Luna uh
thank you very much Mr chair and um just
as um Senator Lang talked about majority
and minority positions um uh in fact in
the house there was only there was no
minority position um on this the uh the
house bill uh was recommended ought to
pass out a committee a 20 nothing and
was voted up on the consent calendar and
I think given the um given the impact
that that uh that this type of
legislation would have across the state
for all School District districts and I
agree with what Senator Lane was talking
about that that um that that districts
do in some cases have challenges um
finding um um uh finding teachers and
for certain areas uh just as what
Senator Apprentice was uh was saying as
well that uh that the house uh position
does provide uh local school boards with
the flexibility in in in Senator Lang's
initial um uh uh scenario where um where
somebody needed to be um you know they'
they've got they've got halftime
requirements well the 20 hours in the uh
in the house version provides for that
but at the same time it also um helps to
assure the high standards and high
quality that um that that um that people
across the granite state hardworking
Granite Staters expect to find in their
Public Schools um um again 20 to nothing
the house was behind it um and uh and
I'd say if we want to give this a try
something much closer to the house
position would be uh would be would be
maybe something that um that could be
introduced and the effective date is is
right I
think uh July 1 2025 I I I still I have
one more other question for the
Department um on one a there Roman 1A it
talks about uh in a local or Statewide
teacher shortage content
area does the department decare teacher
shortage areas does the local the local
Administration can declare they have a
shortage communicate that with you can
you tell explain the process to me
please yes uh thank you chair um so
there are actually there's two different
critical shortage designations there's a
Statewide and that's based on a survey
that the department conducts every
October of all the districts and
position they've had trouble filling um
so we do a Statewide
list however there's a statutory
provision and I don't remember the
statute off the top of my head I
apologize that says that a local school
board May declare a local shortage and
notify the department that they have
declared the local shortage so if they
can't get a physics teacher let's say in
Franklin Franklin can declare a local
critical shortage not the school board
would vote on it they notify us that
they've done this and then what that
does is it lowers um it lowers the entry
bar into the alternative pathway the
site based licensing pathway it doesn't
change the end the end is still up here
but it does require less to come in into
the site into that alternative pathway
so and it matches the state if we had
declared one Statewide that's that's
what I thought was in statute and my my
concern in if that portion of that a is
left
off uh then we are
in conflict with what we have in statute
to a degree but it's also leaving I
believe uh this if this were to
pass to allow this
flexibility to hire folks in a job I
understand Senator Lang's perspective
where the local school board will make
the decision that we need this but I am
concerned that um this came about as the
teacher shortage which we had during the
pandemic and we were looking at how can
we alleviate it's also coming up out as
a result of we have folks coming out of
the community college system to teach
that don't have a credential of any kind
so therefore are not allowed to teach in
the school which is a concern if I were
administrator I'd let them lease the
room for a dollar a year and we'd have
it done
but uh I I think that we have to have
some criteria or else I think there's
room for
abuse on this
legislation represent
Hall I would just say that the Senate
version to me weakened the teaching
profession and it's and it's not good
for
kids so again I I'm going to use
especially given the house language of
you know there has to be a certified
shortage of some sort before you can
start stepping into the part-time
position um again does not give local
school boards flexibility what if I just
need to teach I have a full-time math
teacher I have one more algebra one
class I got to fill it's not exactly a
shortage I'm not going to declare a
shortage because I need to add for my
high school course I have too many kids
that want to take it and I need to add
one more class that's not going to I'm
not going to declare shortage on that
but then I wouldn't be able to hire
someone who might be able to teach that
that on a part-time basis because the
shortage won't won't be declared unless
every time we have a vacancy the school
board's going to immediately vote I I
just want you to consider the amount of
hurdles we putting in front of local
school boards be able to fill needs
within their District um and and why
again um in certain that we don't trust
local school boards to be able to make
these
determinations um the Senate's putting
full faith and trust in local school
boards to be able to say I'm they're
going to do what's in the best interest
of schools and if they don't have a
qualified candidate they won't fill the
position
and we believe that I don't think the
state needs to step in and make that
determination on the part-time basis for
these part-time positions that may be
only one math class or one art class or
one Comm uh uh computer science class
why does a state need to step in if the
local school board can make that
determination in in amongst themselves
if we trust them to make that
determination if we don't trust them
then I understand why you say we need
the state to step in and create a an
issuance of an adjunct authorization
and have a new requirement at the state
level uh for that but I trust that
they'll be able to make these decisions
I trust our local uh voters to vote the
people who are responsible for education
in I trust those people who are voted in
to make the best determination for the
district and for the
students are you willing to go into
caucus and consider leaving a in taking
B out and see
in that's a new question question if
you're in charge of Mr Mr chair yeah Ju
Just just before that just to address
what Senator Lang was was talking about
you know so so I served on a school
board for 12 years chaired it for eight
years and uh and occasionally we did um
uh have to fill a um a one class uh
position so we would offer a um uh a
plus contract to an existing full-time
teacher to uh to take that uh take that
class so school boards already have the
um the the the the tools and the
capability to to f fulfill teaching of a
class with an existing full-time um
teacher with a plus with a plus contract
and do so um to you know making sure
that um that students are receiving high
quality education and doesn't require
any change in the current law to be able
to um to do that now so um um so you
know just saying that that that I think
the um the
the the policy that that is contained in
the house bill provides the the
flexibility beyond that beyond that that
one additional class um to uh to be able
to address the needs of um of districts
and uh and I'd love to see us um you
know stand on that as uh as the outcome
here follow yes so what what happens if
uh existing teacher doesn't want to
teach it there's nobody in the school
district that says I want to teach this
class I've got my plates full I have
enough stuff going on in my life I don't
want to teach it you know I think that's
that's a question I um I didn't see it
at all in my 12 years on the U the
Hopkinson board um uh I I certainly
can't rule out that uh that that um that
that hasn't happened um anywhere but I
think there's probably some flexibility
there through um through alt
certifications or some sort of uh you
know um uh exception that could be uh
granted through the uh through the the
board of through the um through the
State Board uh through the department of
Ed uh that uh that ensures that we're um
that we're you know providing high
quality instruction to um to our
students more follow up yes go ahead so
again so with your 12 years on hopon
Schoolboard did you ever fire a teacher
that's your was certified by the Board
of
Education or non-renew a
contract sure I mean we've we've
non-renewed contracts I mean I I um uh
certainly believe in and you U you you
staff accordingly and um and when when
we've seen you know uh growth and and
and dips in in enrollment we would
certainly um staff accordingly uh on all
that but but but um but in in in in my
experience I think those are those are
done through through riffs obviously but
you try to try to manage your your
Staffing through other you know ways of
doing it too Rift would be would be made
sort of a last resort uh on that but um
but you know also in my experience as a
as a parent um you know certainly our
kids had um had their favorite teachers
and their less favorite teachers and
that might rub off on parents but what I
learned being on the board was that some
of maybe my kids less favorite teachers
happen to be other kids most favorite
teachers so it's it's it's hard for me
to say as a as a as a parent that has
Schoolboard experience that uh that that
just one perspective on on on
on on a teacher is uh is enough
again my my only point was it's not an
absolute a certification from the
Department of Education is not an
absolute that this is a great teacher is
this is even a good teacher right that's
not an absolute statement and that's
what this bill is seeking the Senate
version of this bill is recognizing is
that it's not an absolute statement that
it's not just because a a teacher has a
certification doesn't absolutely mean
that they're going to be a phenomenal
teacher in my school or even a good
teacher in my school and again on the
school board I can tell you that we
non-renewed contracts for poor
performance right that that especially
in the before they reach tenure right
someone who came into the profession
this bill is seeking to recognize that
again you don't need a certification to
be a good teacher you can be a good
teacher without a certification
especially in certain content areas
where certification isn't necessarily
required um and may you may have an
alternative teacher path but why do we
need to have the state involvement in
the conversation why can't a local
school board who has the best interest
of the their students in mind be able to
find somebody who doesn't isn't a
full-time certified teacher doesn't want
to go down the alternative teacher path
but they're willing to step in and teach
one class two class three classes for
the school district across possibly
multiple districts um I I think that the
state should allow that flexibility
again it helps the teacher shortage um
that we have now to allow some of these
one-offs like I said to where you have
that that plus one contract and nobody
wants it I can bring in maybe my local
CPA who might be able to teach a basic
algebra 1 course if I bet if I if I go
through the process doesn't need to go
to the board of education for that um we
want to allow that flexibility at the
local level so we don't have all these
administrative and governmental hurdles
for school districts to get the best uh
outcome for their teach for their
students yes repesent follow up on on
your comment about the overages um in my
district they were fought over you know
how come you gave them an orage and not
me that was the the the problem wasn't
that there weren't people to fill them
the problem was there were too many
people that wanted that orage you know
teachers always looking to make more
money and they they willingly from my
experience accept that position for the
point point an extra point
to that's not a problem okay we're going
to go into Cox I just want to make one
comment because uh what I saw as an
administrator in schools during the time
I supervised and managed hundreds and
hundreds of of Staff members across this
country
and during the time that I was there I
recommended non- retention to the board
on 13 tenured
teachers and that happens if you go
through needs improvement process if you
go through evaluation process and do
things correctly yes in any profession
there are folks which are not cutting
the mustard certainly if I'm going to go
to a surgeon and deal with putting a
stint in I'm going to try to find the
best surgeon I can and that
certification means something to me um
last lastly there's a small District up
my way has about 67 kids in it and the
library happens to be across the street
in a public library where the person has
no
certification however that librarian
knows the community knows what's in that
Library uh loves literature and and and
and top-notch in technology as well this
bill would help provide that
authorization that they need so they
rather than having to hire a librarian
within the school when they don't have
the resources they can use the librarian
across the
street
so so we we'll break in the caucus right
now this what I thought we're talking
about part-time teachers right
now I wonder how many of the part-time
teachers will come in to help out are
they actually trying to become full-time
teachers do they want to continue teach
or may they maybe they're just doing
this for an additional experience or to
you know to to try something different
they may not necessarily continue as a
as a teacher yeah substitute teachers
some are contracted sometimes you have a
a contracted individual that's going to
be a full-time sub within a school
district and they just go from school to
school in certain days the rest of them
are not contracted Personnel don't come
under the negotiated agreement at all um
they their salary is set by the school
board it might be 25 bucks a day 75
bucks a day whatever 100 whatever the
going rate is so uh I I think that's a a
different area that we're trying to
address here than within this particular
legislation let's go to caucus I gotta
run to another COC okay upstairs all
right I'll try to get back if you're
still at it okay thank you very much
Senator okay we'll go on cus we have the
rooms right across the hallway we have
two of them two
officers
for
e
e e
okay let let's go ahead and start I know
that some people were already they'll
come back and I know Senator Apprentice
had to leave
um what what the house would like to
propose and we have one area we'd like
to propose and then a second which we'd
like to uh
discuss um leaving the house version as
is
with
um part a
remaining
in taking part B and putting a period
after the field of authorization
period and leaving c as
is and the rest of the bill as is that's
with change of effective date oh with
effective date change yes
um what would we have the effective date
on that oh yeah days 60 days yes
that's that the other if this is not
palatable then we do have an issue which
we really would like to address and it
brought about part of the rationale for
putting this bill forward uh we take the
Senate
version dealing with part-time
teacher and write this so that we
can allow the adjunct
and teacher teaching staff instructional
staff that has the master's degrees at
the community college system in the
University of system New Hampshire to be
able to come down and work in the
schools uh 20 hours per week or that
part's a little bit for du andr for dual
and concurrent enrollment right now they
can't do that we have a significant
problem in our larger cities regarding
that right now I.E Manchester and I
think that's been communicated to us is
that
correct Mr applebe pardon
me
okay running
start okay
okay
yeah so that that's that this is an area
that it was brought up in our
discussions when we passed this thing
out of the committee uh in education
here in the house and it it's part of
the rationale we we also support the
other side of the coin there that's why
we're offering the first oper you know
change here taking out part of B but if
that's not palatable we'd like to really
just change some quick word smithing and
also require for the adjunct to have the
criminal background
check from the college system that may
not be occurring for all right now
one B totally that paragraph no after
the word authorization stop right there
the individual must have earned a
bachelor's degree or hire with a major
in or related to the field of
authorization period
okay and leaving part c as is
and if that doesn't work we'd like to
propose to uh aced to the Senate version
by amending it to reflect what we need
for the community higher education to do
their uh their class we'd have to get
the wording from Mr applebe here because
it's just obviously not just concurrent
dual enrollment it's other courses which
are taught by them in our
schools so it's it's it's courses that
that lead to college
credit that's correct so no no let's
let's get
that thank you it's actually now become
even in critical shortage areas Franklin
is is partner with Lakes Region
Community College to cover some of their
classes at the high school with
Community College faculty so it's not
only college credit now it's
actually and it works out well for the
college because now they can keep an
instructor busy full
Time by having them maybe teach a period
or two at the high school and the rest
of the time at the
college inter it's a sharing of
resources I see what you're saying so
follow so I clarify this I I I'm not
going to speak for of word but the first
option is an option for me so I'll look
at I said the first option you outlined
is not an option for for me but the
second option I'll consider is your idea
that we would basically say that if
you're an instructor at the University
of Si New Hampshire or a community
college system of Hampshire you're
eligible to teach without a teaching
certification within the within the
public school system is that theet
statement making and with criminal
background check that right but again
Senate position already has that if we
just added to the Senate position and
it's an incremental improvement from
what it is it allows for 30 hour
part-time teach up to
20 didn't you say that representa yeah
yeah we we we stayed with the 20 on even
with the adjunct Steve does that work
for you uh uh
so cons The Ward and I go confirm for a
little bit yeah and if you're if you're
good with that we can probably get Mr
Apple to write some language for
us it's right
Steve just to be clear again so make
sure sen the ward I are talk about the
same thing we're going to adopt Senate
language with a new I'm going to call it
Roman numeral 3 reing Roman numeral
three to four and it would say something
along the lines of in
um that instructors at the University
system of or the community college
system shall be eligible to teach in
public school system without a state
credential or language to that effect
just to just to be clear I don't know if
it's instructors or what the because I
think there
are different levels of of um people who
provide instruction at the college level
I'll consult with both systems to get
the wording correct um and I assume you
want this like by
tomorrow okay yeah yeah I'll make a
couple of calls and get the wording
right and and my understanding that
we're we're talking about um you know uh
professionals at these at you know
whether they're professional full-time
faculty or adjunct faculty that they are
um they're they're they're credentialed
at that
they they let me let me say another way
that they that they have the credentials
um to be able to teach in these their
college classes yes that would be the
that would be the intention they
wouldn't be down here working in our
schools unless they had that Masters in
that subject area
um yeah and I and I I I I I think that's
what we're that's what we're going after
but I think May there may be some we
have to be careful though because Sno
requires bachelors
and schools are using
Snoop for their running start concurrent
dual enrollment e start all
that yeah
I I guess let's on the ward first and I
talk about whether or not we can accept
that position because if you can't then
there's no reason to send H down chasing
language but but you know but we may
want to be cautious if we want to limit
it only to our seven schools and three
fouryear I I'm being I'm good with that
you know we should pushing concurrent
dual enrollment with our system not
necessarily with
Snoop I only have 20 minutes before my
next come yeah you and us together we
back 11:30 11 I'm gent my one my one
with a house with Glen tur committee
took all five minutes great well L
lenn's pretty good with that you
know
e
e e
right Mr chair if I may go ahead so the
Senate would agree to drop the hours to
20 um we agreed to the criminal
background check for for part-time
teachers uh we agreed to the code of
conduct being subject to the codee of
conduct for part-time teachers and we
agree that all of those Provisions would
only apply to instructors from the
University system of the Hampshire or
the community colleges of New Hampshire
who will now be eligible to be able to
teach in our Public Schools without
further
credentialing that's what we would agree
to yep we're good with that it's going
to be written by uh Mr Mr Apple be and
we should have the draft by three
o'clock today yeah I I'm I'm generally
good with good with this I'm I'm I'm
cons I'm very concerned about the um the
the the language that how it applies to
which faculty members would be um would
would have the credentials with which to
do this so I just need to see that final
language Mr app I'm going to consult
with both systems but it would be my
expectation that it would it would refer
to this as faculty members of either
system um so as to not miss a particular
designation that they have for someone
when it comes to the credential involved
certainly at the four-year level it's
almost always the case that if you're
teaching a bachelor's level you need a
master's and at the community college
level I will check on what their
requirements are there could be
instances where an auto mechanic at
nhti may not have a degree but that
would be okay our CTE centers today so
that's already available in the CTE so
we don't got to go that route all we
need to do is ensure that these people
are are are teaching and instructing in
the public schools a course that's
recognized as concurrent dual enrollment
or some other such type program
where or are you talking about just
filling a hole that's not we're we're
just opening it up to make them eligible
to teach a part-time class regardless
what the subject matter is if they're if
they're an instructor at the University
system or nhti so again that one math
class they might be teaching AP Physics
right AP Physics is a great example and
that's needed yes and so just allowed
any any faculty from those two systems
would be able to come into the school
and teach or be contracted to teach or
be an employ part-time employee without
having to go to the board of education
to go chase down now they sort of that's
good in my district right now some of
the AP courses are taught online it'd be
good to have one of those bodies in the
classroom eyeball to eyeball my my
concern is that you know that I want
these people to be faculty members not
teaching assistants not PhD students
that are providing first year
instruction to uh you know first year
students that that they're so you know
with all these different levels at the
higher education in higher education
that that are providing instruction that
it's not all of them it's not a grad
student who's a teaching assistant
specific you know group thank you can
you convey that to Mark Rubenstein and
to Kathy yes thank
you thank you okay thank you so we we
are agreeing with that and uh we'll move
forward with the concurring with what we
so you'll write up we'll write up a COC
report yeah doing that we'll get in
advance just in case we need to tweak a
little bit of something but signature is
the vote Yes yeah yeah we can see it
today yeah
okay thank you very much for attending
today department
members know I'm getting a little more
used to the Senate we run a little
Lo just just a little
bit
weour
e
e e
well well I'm going to go ahead and
start we're right we're right at this
time 11:30 we're absent one on our side
but that's fine um so we're here today
continuing from a recess HB 1665 this is
the uh bill that's dealing with the
education Freedom
accounts and
um let's continue our conversation here
uh Senator Lang is there any movement
sure so the Senate the Senate would
agree to some um minor amendments um if
if the house agrees to them um in
section three the phaseout grants
will'll will'll agree to reduce it to um
just a two-year extension instead of a
three-year extension go so going to 2028
instead of 2029 so that reduces the
extension from the current law that's
going to expire and we would agree to
strip section five completely from the
bill which is the adma
language and if you agree to that I
think we'll have signatures for
everybody okay we're going to take a
brief two minute and come back
okay look like for is three of
us
e
e e
okay I want to confirm one thing here
the um the proposal put forth by the
Senate has been to leave the 400% that
being the top percentage that you're
moving towards and to look at the phase
out drop that to two
years correct drop it from currently it
says 2029 in the on the on the CATE
version we drop it to 2028 okay the the
house uh position on that is we non-c
concur we're going to drop it
is 400 is the uh top of uh what's
possible in um in your opinion on the
Senate side yes yeah so we non-c
concur well can
we um can we have another break
yep
for
e
e e
okay I'd like to go ahead and following
our break right here um still dealing
with HP
1665 folks I've done this before I can
remember doing one with Senator Reagan
years ago we had 30 different amendments
and we never resolved the bill um so on
this one right here I'm going to pull
back to non-c concurrence and we're
recessing till 9:00 tomorrow
morning thank
you
e
e e
no this is yeah this is yours I um
Senator Bradley
is in another Committee of conference
Senator avard I think told us he was
going to be in
DC sorry I accidentally turned yours off
I was trying to turn mine on oh sorry
yes yes so I think it's just me okay
wonderful um so with this I will reopen
the committee the conference committee
on house bill
1278 um I was looking to see if we'd
have two of our Senate colleagues but
I'm very happy to have Senator Whitley
here um as as I'm not sure if everybody
is aware Senate Bill 499 which has been
was added to House Bill 1278 plus
another section um so $499 was accepted
along with um a paired down version of
the roads bill um in um just previously
so that part is already there it's
already headed to law and I don't
believe that there'll be any challenges
having it through um so that language is
already established um the question the
the house will not acceed to the half a
million dollars in spending that had
been defeated previously in the house it
is not the house position to add a half
a million dollars in um school funding
and uh quite frankly not having it on a
committee Bill where we had people
involved in that in the first place
makes it even more challenging to accept
that change um so because that language
because the language in the rest of the
bill in sections four and five were
already accepted in another conference
committee that should have smooth
sailing and the fact that the house is
rejecting section three um we would seek
the Senate to reced from their Amendment
and to and to exceed to the house
position thank for that I mean I I I
think everyone is very clear now what
this house position is on $
499 and I I think the Senate's proposal
at this point is to retain the portions
that the house has already assed to on
499 keep that on 1278 I don't want to
call it an insurance policy but they're
I think uh just cleare eyed that these
are two policies just those two in the
tor schem Amendment $ 499 House and
Senate are in full agreement so uh the
Senate proposal is to retain those on to
1278 and I think we can have an
agreement there well um thank you I I do
appreciate that offer to add simply what
the house had passed however we already
have that language and I don't want to
put in Jeopardy the assistance to small
towns that need assistance to get their
built roads rebuilt I can't imagine that
it would be rejected Beyond this stage
and I can't imagine that it would move
forward through both bodies um so with
that you know thank you for the offer
however our offer is for the Senate to
reced from their Amendment and concur
with the house sorry representative
Aly yes we may have a problem because
there's a certain there's there's been a
lot of talk about how the governor would
not accept the roads portion and that's
where the insurance policy would come
in thank you that's why the committee
had waited and come back today and I
believe that that question is no longer
a
question I I think the I don't I don't
think it's decided I don't I I don't
think it's as certain as as you
indicated I don't I just don't see a
downside to retaining two important
policies that the House and Senate fully
agree on on both I mean there's no
disagreement about the policy we there's
you know full consensus on that so
there's I don't see the downside of
doing that because and I also don't
think it jeopardizes the disaster relief
I'm sorry to interrupt
you sorry representative Shapiro yes I
would also just say that
um in speaking to representative Edwards
prior to um their session um he was in
full agreement with that idea of us
keeping this on this bill as well and I
I mean I've only heard it um secondhand
but I I think that that's true for
representative Earth as
well yeah and I will say we did have um
representative walner check in with
representative F and representative
Edwards and I believe they are
completely fine um with the addition of
adding those two policies that we just
agreed on WE negotiated in good faith on
that and so they were fine with that is
my understanding so my conversations
with them were different um my
conversations were with them were that
those positions were wonderful as long
as they went along with the ability to
repair the roads in small towns because
if you can't get to school for your
lunch if you can't get to the the
grocery store in order to use your
benefits if it's a summerain event we
have larger problems we have the ability
for that enabling legislation um and
while I do understand that over a large
big ticket item there may be a risk of
it passing both bodies and not
ultimately succeeding I really don't
think a question mark of 25 ,000 raises
to that level I do know that there are
some other areas where um where quite
frankly the Senate is pushing a position
where there may be some question some
question called into effect as well um I
don't I don't believe that holding to
the bill as passed by the house without
the Senate Amendment um put the the Feed
the Children at Risk because I don't
believe that that is at risk especially
when it is with the roads and um
that that is the house position
representative Shir yes I just want to
make clear for I think I can speak for
um others as well as myself that this
that the idea to keep the two um Feed
the Children feed food bills food um
policies on our bill is in no way in um
you know it in no way should be read as
us being against the um disaster Relief
Fund um in fact you know in the house we
voted by we included that in the
amendment by a large margin and I
certainly voted for it and um so I hope
you won't take our um push to keep these
food um policies in this bill is in any
way being against the disaster relief
fund um I think we we all in agreement
with that yeah thank you and I think
that's why it's a strong position in
that that's why I don't think that it's
at the same risk that others believe
that it is um so actually with that I'm
going to I just ask are you on sorry
could you put your microphone on sorry
are are you taking the whole bill away
or are you only are you allowing the
this therapeutic cannabis to go forward
so by by asking the Senate to reced from
their Amendment it would allow the
therapeutic cannabis to move forward so
that everybody doesn't need to
relitigate each of those issues um this
is just this is just a point of trying
to move away from the complications and
piling one bill on top of another I know
that we all have the frustrations are
conquered and none of at this table will
be dealing with the frustrations a
little to the south of us which um I I
definitely understand but we want to
hold to that house
position so if um with that if the
Senate would like to go ahead um I know
that not everybody is here um we will be
ready to yeah so I I'm not ready to make
that agreement particularly without my
colleagues here and so if we want to
just recess until tomorrow and that that
way I can talk to my other Senate
colleagues I I can't make uh on behalf
of the Senate I can't make I hear your
agreement and and I would like to recess
and talk with the other members um I
will need to see if we oh it's 12 hours
so we would be able to do that at some
point so I will find and see what times
are available I know that the day is
stacking up quite well and I will notify
everybody so with that we're in recess